[Musique]
la sortie de l'homme d'affaires louis
audet cette semaine qui suggérait que le
salaire minimum passe environ 20 $
l'heure a provoqué plusieurs réactions
et plusieurs débats on a le plaisir de
recevoir ce soir louis audet le
président du conseil de cogeco bonsoir
monsieur rodez bonsoir monsieur gillioz
merci rodez qu'est ce qui vous motive
profondément à faire une telle
proposition pourquoi vous avez senti le
besoin cette semaine de faire ça
maintenant de proposer une hausse quand
même important du salaire minimum
l'invitation du cercle canadien a
présenté une réflexion personnelle m'a
amené à réfléchir sur ce qui cause les
dérapages de démocratie aux états unis
en france et au royaume uni et c'est
clair que ce sont les différences
économiques exagérée qui engendre ces
dérapages là alors j'ai donc examiner
ce que le salaire minimum 1 rapporte
annuellement à quelqu'un environ 21 1400
dollars le seul et le seuil de pauvreté
au canada se situe entre 25 et 30 de
1000 dollars suivant l'endroit où les
gens habitent ou le nombre de personnes
dans le foyer et c'est donc clair que
moi j'ai proposé 20 dollars je suis pas
un économiste pu suggérer 19 oui pour
moi c'est un peu pareil il s'agit de
placer des gens au dessus du seuil de la
pauvreté mais pourquoi ça vous préoccupe
particulièrement est profondément est
fondamentalement et personnellement tout
simplement parce que lorsque il y adeux
l'insatisfaction
basé sur des inégalités exagéré la
cohésion sociale d'un pays est perdus
c'est ce que vous voyez au sud de la
frontière dans le moment c'est ce que
vous avez vu avec les gilets jaunes
c'est ce que vous voyez avec braque cité
avec bruxelles et les problèmes ne font
que commencer à faire surface c'est ce
que vous créez en six mois comme la
démocratie est mise à mal ouais et vous
craignez que ça puisse arriver chez nous
également c'est ça je ne serai pas que
je crains beaucoup que ça arrive chez
nous parce que chez nous on est déjà une
certain une mobilité sociale qui est
supérieure à la moyenne et voisines des
pays scandinaves
mais à la lumière de sang la question
devient plus est ce que nous rémunérons
les gens pour qu'ils puissent vivre
dignement
vie et ma conclusion c'est est pas tout
à fait votre proposition était bien
reçue par les syndicats mais elle a été
rejetée par les organismes patronaux par
le gouvernement du québec également vous
faut entendre le ministre jean boulet
faut quand même y aller de manière
progressive à l'avait bien dit dowler
une augmentation devrait 48% selon moi
ça crée un choc économique important
il y aurait vraisemblablement des mises
à pied par terre des licenciements et
l'impact sur le décrochage scolaire
pourrait quand même mouché est important
comment vous réagissez à sa vision mais
je suis d'accord avec le ministre ne lui
ai jamais dit qu'il fallait donner un
qu'il fallait procéder on est sur le
coup ça prend un système intelligent
d'implantations jugées riscle
implantations soit pu rattraper c'est
vrai mais par contre il faut tenir
compte des répercussions que ça peut
avoir dans les strates salariale plus
élevé donc il faut aller par étape mais
ça prend un plan intelligent sur son ghz
et d'un gouvernement qui ont qui ont là
le pouvoir de faire cela ce n'est pas
les compagnies je comprends mais je vous
invite quand même à préciser votre
pensée puisque c'est vous qui a mené le
dollar cette semaine on en parle parce
que vous en parlez préciser votre pensée
sur combien temps devrait se rendre à 20
$ adore
écoutez moi je pense que trois heures
s'est approprié mais encore une fois
comprenons-nous là moi je ne suis pas un
économiste j'ai lancé une idée qui
m'apparaissait est raisonnable pour que
les gens puissent vivre dans la dignité
quand je regarde les mères
monoparentales quand je regarde ce qui
se passe avec les banques alimentaires
alors c'est sur cette base là que j'ai
créé mes suggestions à partir de là
c'est le rôle des gouvernements de
décider quelles sont les étapes à suivre
et comment s'assurer que la mesure soit
compétitivement neutre qu'elle soit qui
est uniformément pour que personne soit
désavantagé dans cet exercice qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ceux qui disent bon
monsieur au défunt pour proposer ça ça
concerne pas vraiment son entreprise les
employés chez cogeco sont au delà du
salaire minimum il ya quand même des
milliers d'entreprises des pme qui sont
au salaire minimum et qui pourrait pas
vraiment vivre avec une hausse
importante du salaire minimum mais ma
réponse à 100 est très simple je
comprends que ça cause les inquiétudes
vivent à plusieurs entrepreneurs et j'en
suis sincèrement désolé parce que moi je
ne voulais pas nuire à personne dans
cette histoire là mais une chose est
claire si la mesure est amené plus
rapidement qu actuellement mais quand
même par étape et si elle est appliquée
uniformément ça va être compétitivement
neutre pour ces compagnies là c'est
certain que la société va payer certains
bien un petit peu plus cher mais pas
beaucoup plus cher comparativement à l'
avantage que les personnes défavorisées
vont en tirer lundi dans votre discours
vous avez aussi dit que l'impôt à payer
sur les successions des entrepreneurs
familiaux est une erreur qui fiscale qui
doit être corrigé une erreur fiscale qui
décourage
l'entrepreneuriat familiale est ce qu'il
faut faire un lien entre votre propos
sur la réduction de l'impôt sur les
successions familiales et votre
proposition d'augmenter salaire minimum
non il n'y a pas de lien j'ai apporté à
cette conférence la 3e sujet celui du
salaire minimum celui de l'impôt sur le
passage des compagnies d'une génération
à l'autre qui nuit à la rétention des
entreprises et à la prospérité et celui
des personnes en situation d'itinérance
j'avais donc trop au sujet de ma
conférence
distincts mais vous avez quand même
cette volonté que le gouvernement
modifie
la l'impôt sur la succession des
entreprises familiales qui peut
décourager l'entrepreneuriat familiale
vous l'avez quand même oui j'ai aussi
clair ou est tout à fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'il ya quatorze pays
de l' ocde qui ont peu ou pas d'impôts
sur le passage d'une entreprise ça veut
pas dire qu'ils n'ont pas d'impôts sur
les transmissions d'argent mais ils en
ont sur le passage des actions
entreprises pour s'assurer que les
entreprises demeurent de propriété
locale dans notre cas on parle de
propriété canadienne on parle de famille
qui continue mais il va sans dire que si
la famille éventuellement vend son
entreprise il va sans dire qu'il
faudrait qu'elle pèse on n'est pas
parfait monsieur des merci d'avoir été
avec nous c'est un plaisir de vous
recevoir merci pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit